hi in this video I will talk about
interference as the name suggests
interference or substances that
interferes with some processes in
immunology interference mediate innate
immune responses and specially
interference are very important for
protections against viruses so let's see
what happens when a virus invades a cell
so here are some epithelial cells and
let's say a virus invades these
epithelial cells and after viral
invasion what would happen virus would
hijack the translational mechanism of
the cell and would translate its own
viral protein but once a viral proteins
have made the cellular degradation
machineries like proteasome would
degrade the viral proteins that would
enter the ER and be loaded on class 1
MHC molecule the class 1 MHC molecule
would display that final peptide onto
the cell surface
now silver defense mechanisms would
detect that viral peptide one such cell
which can be take this vinyl make viral
peptide is cd8 positive T cells or
cytotoxic T cells cytotoxic T cells
would produce specific enzymes known as
granzymes and perforin which would
ultimately lead to apoptosis of this
viral infected cell and thereby
protecting other cells to get invaded by
the viruses but before this cell dies it
sends out a alarming signal to the
nearby cells and this alarming signal is
very important for other cells because
it would prime other cells to produce
some machinery or producing defense
machineries which can combat against our
viral invasion or which can prevent
viral invasion or even if the virus
invade it can prevent viral propagation
so when the cell dies before it it sends
the interference and the interferon
mediated signaling produced antiviral
defense mechanisms which would prevent a
viral assembly or a final propagate
so let's see on the uninfected cell
there are interferon receptors and the
interferon receptors are normally
tyrosine kinase associated with Janus
kinase so Jeff dimerize upon interferon
binding and jack phosphorylation would
give rise to phosphorylation in step was
related step stat1 and stat2 can
dimerize Witchita each other and
translocate to the nucleus and thereby
giving rise to proteins which can help
the cells to come back against viral
infections in other mode of interferon
mediated signaling could occur in
different way it can also lead to
phosphorylation of check thereby
dimerization of different type of stat
stat can either homodimer eyes or
heterodimer rays giving rise to proteins
which can give rise to viral which can
give rise to protection against viral
invasion now let's see what happens when
when interferon binds to the interferon
receptor and the interferon signalling
happens so it can produce protein kinase
are one of these defense molecules or
protein kinase r which can bind to viral
dsDNA TS RNA and stop translation of
that RNA also protein kinase r can
phosphorylate initiation factor to alpha
which also lead to inhibition of the
viral translation so final translation
machineries could be interfered by the
interferon mediated molecules second
mode of defense is by 2 v illegal a
synthase which can put a mark on the
mRNA that would be further degraded by
rnase l family thereby again preventing
the viral translation machinery viral
translation and the third one is
inhibition of the viral assembly they
say all the viral proteins are there it
is produced but it need to be assembly
in a manner to produce a functional
virus and that process could be
inhibited by MX proteins
MX protein can altmer eyes and interfere
with viral assemblies so these are some
possible ways by which interferon
mediated downstream signaling can
produce antiviral defense machineries
and all these difference machineries can
work together or individually to protect
a cell from further viral infection when
even if the virus can get in but it
cannot propagate much more because it's
translation and assembly all this
process could be interfered by
interferon in simple words interfere
interferes interference interferes with
the viral assembly or vinyl viral life
processes that's how it can help the
cell to create a defense against viral
invasion I hope you liked this video and
video is informative in my next video I
will discuss about the different type of
interference okay
thanks for watching like subscribe and
share thank you